I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle thank you for being with us
tonight the Biden honey pot that's sweet
and it's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
based on the executive order that I
signed in response to Russia's initial
intervention in Ukraine we're imposing
sanctions on more senior officials of
the Russian government
in addition
we are today sanctioning a number of
other individuals with substantial
resources and influence who provide
material support to the Russian
leadership
yes during the Obama Administration if
you were a well-known oligarch from the
former Soviet Union or one of its old
block countries you knew that there was
a serious risk that you could be placed
on a U.S sanctions list and therefore
you could be hobbled financially
but some oligarchs had friends in high
places as in the Obama Biden
Administration meet Ukrainian oligarch
Elena batarina and kazakhstani oligarch
Kenneth rakishev both of who somehow
escaped Obama's sanctions how did they
do that well I don't know but maybe they
funneled big piles of cash to the family
of Obama's VP
well courtesy of the house oversight
committee we know that Ms batarina paid
3.5 million dollars to a shell company
associated with Hunter Biden and Devin
Archer and Mr rakeshov meanwhile wired
142 300 to another bank account used by
Hunter and Archer that's kind of an odd
sum I thought well until I realized that
the next day on April 23rd 2014 Hunter
Biden paid that exact amount 142
thousand three hundred dollars to
purchase an expensive new toy a Fisker
sports car
but I guess that wasn't flashy enough so
he switched it to a Porsche convertible
now who knew Porsches were considered
hooker magnets I didn't and it gets
better those same two foreign oligarchs
ended up having dinner with Joe Biden in
2014 and 2015. oh that's just another
silly coincidence
and if you thought the White House would
respond with a denial
think again they'd rather insult your
intelligence what again well Biden's
Deputy comms director Kate Berner
replied to a Politico piece saying the
memo doesn't show a direct payment to
Joe Biden okay
try to get get your minds wrapped around
this
his communication shop is not denying
that the Biden family is bought and paid
for by these foreign adversaries but
they want everyone to know that the
oligarchs didn't write checks directly
to Joe himself
now
they would dismiss this I mean this is
no shock to any of us
and what are they going to say that the
house committee's findings are wrong no
that 20 million dollars in payments from
foreign sources didn't go to the bidens
and their Associates
are all the bank records just part of
Hillary's old vast right-wing conspiracy
or I don't know are we to believe that
Devin Archer Tony bobolinski They Were
Somehow lying when they said that Joe
Biden was frequently on calls with
Hunter's foreign partners
well our own peter Ducey and I love this
moment did what actual reporters are
supposed to do today he asked President
Biden for an explanation
there's this testimony now where one of
your son's former business associates is
claiming that you were on speakerphone a
lot with them talking business is that
what whatever job business and everyone
and I know you'd have a lousy question
well what do you it's why is that a
lousy question thank you because it's
not true
thank you Mr President
a lousy question what what what is the a
good question for Joe Biden what's your
favorite color
what astrological sign are you
now anyone with a White House Press
badge who doesn't demand answers on this
topic should not show up to work at all
tomorrow
just send your resume to the DNC and get
it over with
because the truth is they all know what
we all know that Hunters only knowledge
about foreign transactions involved
hookers and the only High returns he
could promise were from cocaine
his only expertise back then and now is
limited to one area
selling access to his father and his
father's vast network of contacts
in fact Biden's protectorate
looking at this is so Shameless though
they don't even pretend to defend the
propriety of the money flow
I think you have a nothing Burger of an
investigation where are the high crimes
misdemeanors that have to do with jokes
so far both investigations in the
oversight and Judiciary committees have
not been able to to find that direct
link there's no actual proof that the
president had benefited financially from
his son's foreign business dealing
now of course it's always been one big
Biden money pot right or a honey pot
it's all sweet which Hunter himself
noted and is now Infamous electronic
communications his emails that revealed
his payments to jrb hmm wonder who that
might be and in his text to his daughter
Naomi he complained about having to give
his father half his salary
so the not so prodigal son was carrying
a heavy load while supporting his heavy
drug habit it seems
the question isn't whether Joe Biden
himself got direct payments from foreign
business interests even oligarchs he's
stupid but he's not that stupid right
but he benefited because his son
benefited his only remaining son and it
sent a message to the world that
American policy was for sale
and what policy in particular was for
sale well we may not ever know but as
long as Joe Biden is in power a cloud of
corruption hangs over this White House
take his announcement yesterday brazenly
crippling America's uranium mining
capacity by making one million Acres
permanently off limits for any type of
mining it's going to come from the
sacrifices of dealing with taking on the
climate crisis folks
these are investments on our planet
our people in America itself
protecting our outdoor Treasures making
our nation more resilient
Treasures is a lot of treasures he wants
to protect but it's just more green
smoke because uranium that's obviously
found in this million acres is vital not
just for nuclear power plants but for
our weapon systems
in what country when you think about how
this is all being cordoned off can't do
any mining here is one of the biggest
beneficiaries of Joe's courageous
decision
none other than Kazakhstan home of one
of Biden's preferred oligarchs and one
of his sons sugar daddies it's now
guaranteed to remain the dominant
supplier of uranium to the United States
with its 35 percent share
well it all could really make perfect
sense couldn't it one of the most
crooked families in American politics is
responsible for making America
permanently dependent on one of the most
crooked countries on the face of the
planet
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else